everyone's talking about Ralph breaks
the internet and we've already seen some
pretty wild fan theories about it
seriously these theories will completely
change the way you see this movie let's
check out these 10 fan theories about
Ralph breaks the internet that are
game-changers princess stalker one of
the best scenes in the entire movie is
the Disney Princess seem when vanellope
is running from the stormtroopers in oh
my Disney she glitches straight into the
princess dressing room every single
Disney Princess was there but when they
realize they have an intruder the
reaction is a little extreme all of the
princesses are ready to attack whoever
has entered their domain Cinderella even
breaks her glass slipper to make an
impromptu weapon Merida draws her bow
it's crazy this doesn't seem like quite
a normal reaction to someone coming into
your dressing room but one fan theory on
deviantART thinks there might be a
little more to the story
user track force suggests that the
princesses have a stalker they cite Elsa
in particular with one DreamWorks
character Jack Frost from Guardians Elsa
and Jack Frost are often shipped
together in fanfic but this theory
suggests that Jack Frost has been
stalking Elsa later comments mentioned
maybe it's hiccup from How to Train Your
Dragon hiccup is often shipped with
Meredith we don't know if it's a
DreamWorks character that is stalking
these princesses but either way there's
definitely more to the story these
princesses were instantly ready to fight
whoever it was and they were shocked
when it was vanilla pee the end of
vanilla P some of these fan theories are
a little dark and if stalking isn't dark
enough for you listen to this theory
from the YouTube user the fan girl the
first thing you have to remember for
this theory is the story of turbo in
wreck-it Ralph turbo was a character who
left his game he began to invade and
sabotage other games be confident
I'm malleable my resume okay it's also
important to remember that if a
character is caught outside of their
game and they meet their end they can't
regenerate now every character is made
up of coding but Penelope is from a
really old game her coat is nothing like
the code and slaughter race but shank
says she adds Penelope's code to
slaughter race but this is a huge
problem what about new updates to the
game will vanilla peas code stay in and
eventually all great games come to an
end one day
slaughter race will go to the great
video game store in the sky
and then what well that will be the end
of vanellope where will she go after
that she will either have to live with
an out-of-date code on the internet or
go back and live with Ralph's oh no this
is definitely not explained well what
will happen to vanellope when ralph
retires Ralph has been wrecking things
in the fix-it felix game for almost 40
years
wreck-it ralph his game is really old
eventually his game will stop working or
the arcade will close down that will be
really sad wherever all these characters
go it's just not realistic to think that
their games will last forever well a
discussion on reddit has some ideas
there's a thread on the fan theories
subreddit someone points out that
vanellope seems to get a pass on going
turbo it just isn't as big of a deal
let's assume that shank adding vanilla
Pease code does work and Penelope gets
to stay in solder race forever could she
add the code for any other characters
reddit user genealogy fan 77 things that
slaughter race would actually be perfect
for Ralph okay we know ralph was
terrified of the game but if you didn't
have to worry about being permanently
deleted it might not seem so bad
spotter race needs things to get
constantly destroyed Ralph is the
perfect candidate for that he is called
wreck-it Ralph after all he could make
the game super interesting and wreck new
stuff all the time plus his BFF Penelope
lives there it would be the perfect
place for Ralph to go when fix-it Felix
gets unplugged one day King candy broke
the game remember King candy in wreck-it
Ralph he was the king of sugar rush
and he was determined to keep vanellope
from racing he told everyone it was
because of her glitch but really he had
altered her code if an LP raced and
crossed the finish line the game would
reset everyone would remember that
vanellope was actually a princess and in
charge of the land of sugar rush then we
found out that king candy was actually
turbo this reddit theory suggests that
King candy messed with the code so much
it actually destroyed the game forcing
vanellope and Ralph to go to the
Internet we know what you're thinking
Ralph made a new track and vanellope
fought for control of the car with the
girl playing her character the little
girl pulled so hard on the wheel that it
broke but what if the game was boring to
vanellope because of King Candy's messed
up code and perhaps his code gave
vanellope the abilities of fight against
the player controlling her reddit user
Louise one to two seems to think this is
the case was king candy so evil that his
misdeeds continue even after he's gone
what do you think about this theory
Disney Princesses are avatars
these two next theories are all about
the Disney Princesses which might be the
best characters in the whole movie
we meet the Disney Princesses in their
dressing room they take on vanilla P
style and they teach her how to sing in
two important water and find her destiny
they are hilarious and they also save
the day later in the movie now it makes
sense that some of the princesses look
quite a bit different from their
original form animation has changed a
lot since Snow White's made her
appearance in the 1930s you might think
they look a little different because
they were updated into the new animation
style but Bexley us from reddit thinks
there is more to the story what if the
Disney Princesses are avatars of
themselves when we make avatars online
we sometimes like to tweak our
appearances to look a little different
this suggests that the Disney Princesses
are actually playing themselves that is
one interesting theory it would be crazy
if all the princesses were real and they
played themselves on the Internet would
your avatar look like you or would you
make some changes let us know in the
comments section Disney Princesses are
robots
if the avatar theory seems a bit too
far-fetched to you reddit user vex Alice
offers a second theory we know that the
Disney Princess
seem very realistic but all the
princesses are from different times
brave and some wanna take place over a
thousand years ago
even if you just went to buy the movie
release dates Snow White came out before
your grandparents were born so how are
they all existing at the same time and
in the same place it's possible that
they aren't really the princesses
instead they are sort of like robots an
intelligence agent is a special term in
artificial intelligence intelligence
agents are programmed to have a lot of
knowledge and to operate all by
themselves they are even giving goals to
achieve and they react to their
environments this way no one has to
control them the princesses and Ralph
breaks the internet are on the Internet
which means they are just code but if
they are nothing more than a form of
artificial intelligence why do they get
time to chill in their dressing room it
doesn't seem necessary think that's a
crazy theory about the princess
identities wait till you hear about
vanilla Peas identity stay tuned for
that mind-blowing theory a new vanellope
here's a crazy thought there's probably
more than one version of every character
in the movies there are other versions
of the same arcade games in other
arcades there are other editions of
things on the internet it's like a giant
alternate universe theory gaming style
this next theory comes from the fan girl
on YouTube
it is totally likely that sugar rush
will need to be reset at some point
maybe it glitches or the arcade loses
power if sugar rush gets unplugged and
plugs back in the game will reset but
vanellope is gone if the game resets
there could be a whole new vanilla P she
will have the same code as the original
game but she won't have any of the
memories of our vanilla P she probably
won't even know who Ralph is whoa that
is a scary fact can you imagine how
Ralph would feel think about it he sees
the new vanellope and he's so excited
thinking his best friend is back but
then she has no clue who he is and has
no idea of their adventures together
that would hurt Ralph Penelope would
still be on the Internet in slaughter
ace mind blown fangirl that would make
an interesting story for another movie
or maybe a fanfic someone get on that
vanellope is a villain
fangirl points out some pretty major
points in her video about vanellope
going turbo and the big one is that
vanilla pee has a glitch and she is also
written in really old code in the first
movie we know that happened to interpose
goes into other games because he is the
wrong code and he crashes all the other
games wouldn't the same thing be true
about vanilla pee at the beginning of
the sequel Ralph and vanellope go to
play in Tron but the game is messed up
they have obviously played trauma for
did their code mess up the game and of
course Penelope thinks that she is the
one who crashed slaughter race at first
the bad code crashes games this theory
makes us think that vanilla pee is now
programmed to mess up games she probably
doesn't realize it but she might be an
accidental villain the fangirl suggests
that Penelope is doomed just to go from
game to game crashing everything she
touches that's seriously dark Penelope
is so sweet it's crazy to imagine that
she is doomed to never find a game to
call her own
but code just works like that it's hard
to believe that shank could just write
her into the new code maybe shank just
has some mad computer science skills
solder race is actually sugar rush okay
we realize this sounds absolutely crazy
but hear us out first of all look at the
game's sugar rush and slaughter race
have the same initials of SR it's a
racing game sugar rush is a really sweet
game with kids and candy but it's still
hyper competitive seriously those kids
are vicious when they race slaughter
race is dark and urban and it's got more
realistic graphics these wicked dangers
a discussion on the subreddit R / fan
theories raises some interesting points
one user suggests that sugar rush was
the predecessor then it got an upgrade
from arcade classic to console by the
time it's a mass multiplayer online game
it just looks totally different
they needed to keep up with the trends
in the video game world but another user
pointed out that according to mr. Litvak
the company that made sugar rush went
out of business a long time ago but
sugar rush had a ton of fans that grew
up to love video games solder race might
be a homage to the original game it
might have been designed by a fan what's
your favorite video game is it a new
game or an old one
in the comments below shank is Penelope
this theory is kind of a spin-off of the
previous theory reddit user throw the
brick blew our minds with this idea they
suggest that vanellope von schweetz is
shank whoa crazy right first of all
vanellope and shank are both popular
girl racers who are amazing drivers and
Showtime let's race they're the best in
their games
honestly girl racers aren't all that
common in video games so there is one
major similarity secondly they have the
same style they're both casual and
comfortable they both have dark hair and
big eyes and they're both played by
Jewish actresses this reddit user thinks
that shank is a darker version of
vanellope that would explain why they
get along so well
even though vanellope tries to still
shanks car but they are instant friends
it's because they are so similar if you
believe that slaughter race is a homage
to sugar rush then shank would be a
modern character that is based on
Penelope Penelope wasn't from such a
light hearted game she would probably
look just like shank and if they are the
same that's why shank has such an easy
time adding vanilla peas code to the
game after all she is one tough racer
this theory definitely gives us
something to think about
what do you think about this theory let
us know in the comments and that's it
for the 10 mind-blowing fan theories
about Ralph breaks the internet give
this video a big thumbs up and hit that
subscribe button see you next time
[Music]